bonjour Annie genvar merci beaucoup
d'être notre invité politique ce matin
député du Doubs présidente des
républicains on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Stéphane Vernet de
Ouest-France bonjour Stéphane bonjour
bonjour Annie
hier à l'Assemblée nationale vous n'avez
voté aucune d'émotions de censure ni
celle au pluriel de la nuque ni celle du
rassemblement national ni même déposer
la vôtre êtes-vous ce matin clairement
dans l'opposition
avec tout à fait on n'a pas fait échouer
la censure on s'est opposé à ceux pour
lesquels les moyens
importent peu pourvu qu'elles deviennent
le chaos voilà un de mes collègues a dit
c'est l'union des désordres c'est un
petit coup politique pour mettre un peu
plus la pression sur le gouvernement
mais en réalité chacun savait que
c'était un jeu de duc puisque il ne
parviendrait pas à renverser le
gouvernement et puis quand bien même
avec les des républicains ça aurait pu
marcher vous qui avez sauvé le
gouvernement non on n'a pas sauvé le
gouvernement on agit en responsabilité
ça fait quelques semaines que nous
travaillons à l'Assemblée nationale
imaginons que la motion de censure est
aboutie
et que nous ayons mêlé nos voix à celle
de la de la France insoumise et du
rassemblement national que n'aurait-on
dit des républicains dans cette alliance
contre nature et puis enfin l'essentiel
n'est pas là l'essentiel c'est que si le
gouvernement tombe aujourd'hui Emmanuel
Macron dit sous l'Assemblée nationale ce
sont des semaines d'inaction politique
au moment même où les Français souffrent
terriblement où il y a une crise sociale
et économique énergétique c'est que ça
ou c'est aussi le risque que le groupe
les républicains soit à moins de riz en
cas de dissolution et en cas de
nouvelles vous savez en la matière nul
ne peut prévoir ce que donne une
dissolution on est payé pour le je
rappelle 97 donc je pense qu'il est
prudent de ne pas se livrer à des
conjectures hasardeuses on a agi en
responsabilité en responsabilité on
n'est pas prêt nous à toutes les
compromissions pour gagner une élection
ou pour accéder au pouvoir donc il y a
aussi l'esprit de responsabilité qui
doit prévaloir en la matière ça veut pas
dire du tout un blanc simple pour le
gouvernement ni on va y revenir mais
juste un mot sur le choix de Marine Le
Pen choix un peu surprise Marine Le Pen
qui a annoncé hier qu'elle voterait et
qui a voté le député du rassemble ont
voté la motion de censure de la nuque ça
vous a surpris que ce que vous avez
pensé de se positionnement alors je
pense que elle a voulu faire un coup
politique mais la cible c'est nous c'est
pour pouvoir dire d'ailleurs les
réactions de ces troupes sont tout à
fait caractéristiques c'est pour pouvoir
dire vous voyez les républicains
soutiennent le gouvernement ce qui est
absolument faux on l'a démontré dans
tous les débats et dans nos prises de
position successives on a fait avancer
un le nombre de sujets qui sont utiles
aux français quand on augmente le crédit
d'impôt pour la garde d'enfants on fait
oeuvres utile pour les français quand on
fait voter une diminution du prix du
litre carburant on fait oeuvre utile
pour les Français lorsqu'on baisse on
demande à baisser la fiscalité des
entreprises on fait œuvre utile pour les
Français en réalité la cible c'est nous
on voit bien que Marine Le Pen et
engagée dans une processus où elle veut
se substituer à élève on est un peu le
dernier rempart et donc voilà la cible
c'est c'est nous et c'est pas et c'est
pas le gouvernement en réalité parce
qu'elle savait très bien qu'en sallyon
avec la nuque elle ne ferait pas tomber
le gouvernement et ça fait mal c'est la
cible c'est vous est-ce que vous êtes le
dernier rempart dites-vous mais est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui au sein du groupe les
républicains l'assemblées vous êtes 62
est-ce qu'il y a une unité où est-ce que
contrairement à ce qu'on va comme on
peut l'entendre beaucoup il y a une
espèce de désordre vous êtes 62
travailleurs indépendant il y a pas en
ligne il y a comment comment est-ce que
vous pouvez faire rempart comment est-ce
que vous pouvez avoir cette unité si
vous même vous êtes divisé au sein de ce
groupe
la presse dit beaucoup ce que vous venez
de dire et c'est faux Henri
je crois qu'il faut passer exagérer
d'abord sur la question de la ligne vous
ne trouverez pas un républicain qui vous
dira qu'il n'est pas en accord avec un
certain nombre de fondamentaux que sont
le respect de l'autorité publique
le l'importance de nez au travail
l'importance accordée à la solidarité
bien comprise l'importance attachée au
territoire à la décentralisation tout ça
c'est notre corps plus commun et
personne n'en dise qu'on vient chez nous
après
il nous faut trouver un rythme dans
cette nouvelle configuration
je n'ai je ne vois pas de différence
insurmontable entre nous mais il est
clair que on est sorti très affaiblie de
la présidentielle on est sorti pas aussi
affaibli que certains l'auraient voulu
ou le prédisait des législatives on
occupe la ligne qui est la plus
responsable mais la plus difficile à
expliquer une ligne de responsabilité
qui fait que on ne s'oppose pas par
principe par presque de façon
pavlovienne on est là dans le
rendez-vous de la responsabilité ce qui
nous a conduit à faire accepter encore
une fois un certain nombre de mesures le
Sénat est en train d'examiner la loi
travail on a fait adopter une mesure
très importante qui assimile l'abandon
de poste à la démission et qui n'ouvre
pas droit au chômage ça c'est très
important il faut nous avons notre
boussole et et et elle est intangible
c'est l'intérêt des Français maintenant
le jour où ça sera plus possible de
soutenir ce gouvernement parce que
décidément il n'y aura rien à attendre
de lui et bien
dans son discours Olivier Marleix votre
président de groupe il a dit les
républicains n'hésiteront pas à déposer
eux-mêmes une motion bien sûr si les
circonstances l'exigent c'est quoi les
circonstances écoutez si véritablement
Emmanuel Macron ne réformait pas ce à
quoi finalement il nous a habitués c'est
attentisme c'est ce qui a caractérisé
tout le premier quinquennat s'il n'y
avait aucune des réformes dont la France
a un impérieux besoin si le désordre
était tel ici ou là que il faille
remettre à zéro démocratiquement les
choses par une élection nous prendrions
sans aucun doute nos responsabilités la
possibilité dissolution en réalité
l'arme de la dissolution c'est nous qui
l'avons nous le savons bien mais ce
n'est pas une arme qu'on utilise
inconsidérément ça fait une poignée de
semaine qu'on était élu quel sens
donnerait-on à une
renversement du gouvernement
alors que nous avons six peu piéger et
que nous avons déjà nous les
républicains démontrer que nous étions
utiles aux Français est-ce qu'on peut
imaginer est-ce qu'on peut imaginer un
accord autour de la grande réforme qui
fait parler tout le monde celle des
retraites réformes à venir ce serait
quoi les conditions pour vous entendre
avec le gouvernement autour de ce projet
là on a
toujours prôné une réforme des retraites
que qui est rendue aujourd'hui à
absolument nécessaire le le Comité
d'Orientation des Retraites le dit très
clairement soit vous baissez les
pensions soit vous augmentez les contrer
les cotisations
soit vous jouez sur la durée de
cotisation et sur l'âge nous on a
toujours été invariant sur ce sur ce
sujet donc
avant de répondre à votre question
j'attends de voir le texte que le
gouvernement posera sur la table des
députés parce que sous le président
quinquennat il y a eu des concertations
sans fin qui n'ont abouti à rien une
réforme
sans doute une conversation n'aboutisse
encore à rien de test qui n'a abouti à
rien pour douter que ça soit le cas qui
a un nouveau recul du gouvernement moi
j'attends de voir je sais que c'est une
réforme que le gouvernement c'est
indispensable mais qu'il juge
politiquement
embarrassant donc comment traitera-t-il
politiquement la question il est clair
que nous on continu à mettre la certaine
qu'elle a jusqu'au bout c'est ce que
vous dites
jusqu'au bout non en effet sur les la
question des majorités donc sur la
réforme des retraites on a bien compris
vous attendez de voir le texte il a dit
autre chose il y a Olivier marlacidi il
y a des majorités possibles le pays
n'est pas condamné au blocage c'est ce
qu'il a dit à Elisabeth ça veut dire que
cette majorité possible c'est avec vous
clairement non ça veut dire que lorsque
le gouvernement propose des choses qui
sont qui sont utiles qui sont ajustés à
la situation
pour qu'on peut tenir comme ça pendant
cinq ans avec un cas par cas sur
certains textes c'est tenable pour vous
ça c'est ça c'est le problème du
gouvernement elle vautre ça c'est le
problème du gouvernement en réalité
parce que
il a une majorité relative et divisée
et divisé parce que on se plaît à
souligner les divisions de notre groupe
mais j'aimerais que l'on se penche
l'avantage sur les divisions de la
majorité lorsque le modem pose un
amendement qui est que dont le
gouvernement ne veut absolument pas et
que le modem persiste à le présenter à
le maintenir en séance alors même que le
gouvernement a mis un véto sur ça en dit
long quand même sur la division de la
majorité donc
voilà le problème d'Emmanuel Macron
c'est qu'il a une majorité relative
qu'il a une majorité qui n'est pas
homogène et qui va révéler ses fractures
dans les textes à venir les retraites
je voudrais bien savoir ce que j'aurais
bien savoir ce que Sacha oulier qui est
vraiment un homme de gauche va faire sur
l'immigration j'aurais bien le savoir ce
que le président de la commission des
lois va faire sur la loi immigration
donc tout ça ce sont des auront besoin
d'aller c'est ce que vous leur dites
alors nous sur ces sujets là on a posé
très clairement les termes du débat si
le compte n'y est pas je ne vois pas
pourquoi on soutiendrait le gouvernement
si maintenant le compte est si on a été
l'aiguillon qui pousse la majorité à
agir qu'il adopte qu'il vient sur nos
positions qu'il vient sur nos positions
et non pas nous à eux et bien là quelle
raison aurions-nous de ne pas voter ses
dispositions ça veut pas dire que on se
rallie à la majorité moi je pense que
les républicains ont reçu un héritage
politique dont il d'une certaine façon
qu'ils ont le devoir de transmettre et
rejoindre la majorité c'est faire courir
le risque c'est héritage de se dissoudre
et de s'oublier et ça ça n'est pas
possible une dernière question sur sur
le budget à la séquence qu'on est en
train de vivre entre le projet de loi de
finance en deux parties le PLFSS le
projet de loi de finance sur la sécurité
sociale En cas de partie dont deux
seront rarement discutés et un éventuel
projet de loi de finance rectificative
est-ce qu'on va avoir d'ici la fin de
l'année des séquences avec une quinzaine
de 49-3 chaque fois l'assemblée entre la
première lecture la nouvelle lecture la
l'élection définitive etc est-ce que
vous pensez qu'à chaque fois on aura
droit à une motion de de censure ou
plusieurs et que en fait le Parlement va
pendant quasiment trois mois être sans
arrêt en stop and go avec des débats qui
finalement servent à rien
alors connaissant la nuque et les filles
à mon avis d'épouseront l'émotion de
censure systématique
pour le reste je n'en sais rien il est
clair que là on a la démonstration que
le 49-3 et la traduction de
l'empêchement du gouvernement et
d'Emmanuel Macron puisqu'ils sont
obligés d'utiliser cet outil que la
Constitution
prévoit très clairement
la France insoumise et le rassemblement
national ont choisi de dramatiser cet
outil de montrer que c'était un coup de
force de pouvoir délégitimer ainsi le
gouvernement c'est juste la traduction
que le gouvernement ayant
convenablement pour revenir à votre
positionnement par rapport à la majorité
vous avez évidemment lu d'une interview
de Nicolas Sarkozy un dimanche dans le
Journal du dimanche il vous appelle à
aller plus loin qu'une majorité de
textes par texte à laquelle dont
laquelle de laquelle vous nous parlez
pardon il demande à Emmanuel Macron de
franchir le Rubicon à chercher à faire
un accord politique en bonne et due
forme avec toutes les bonnes volontés
constituer une majorité dans l’intérêt
supérieur du pays je le cite est-ce que
les LR font partie de ces bonnes volonté
rejoignent la majorité ça voudrait dire
valider
nous sommes en séquence budgétaire un
budget
où on emprunte 270 milliards d'euros
emprunt
inégalé à ce jour
où on fait presque 50 milliards de
nouvelles dépenses où on a un déficit
budgétaire de plus de 150 milliards pour
ne parler que du budget
rejoindre la majorité ça signifierait
valider la politique migratoire du
gouvernement qui a laissé
aller les choses dans un dans un laxisme
coupable dont on perçoit aujourd'hui
toutes les conséquences délétères
rejoindre la majorité ça signifierait de
valider la façon dont l'école est
aujourd'hui gérée avec tous les
problèmes qu'on connaît le
communautarisme l'emprise
d'un islamisme militant les
croyances en termes de transmission des
savoirs donc comment voulez-vous que
dans ce paysage dévasté où on a le
sentiment que on ne peut s'appuyer sur
rien de solide nous rejoindrions une
majorité qui a qui a su si mal géré les
affaires de la France ça n'a pas de sens
non recevoir que vous adressez à Nicolas
Sarkozy est-ce que vous regrettez qu'il
est tenu ce genre de propos et qu'il
lance ce genre d'appel dans la période
je crois que cette question a été
tranchée au moment des législatives nous
avons choisi d'être dans une opposition
clairement pour toutes les raisons que
j'ai que j'ai donné
là où je rejoins là où je rejoins
Nicolas Sarkozy parce que dans cette
interview faut voir aussi en creux les
critiques qu'il fait d'Emmanuel Macron
il dit il dit
il dit en substance il n'a pas les
moyens de ses ambitions c'est un
président faible
il dit son échec sur le plan
international
l'Ukraine la Russie
aujourd'hui nos relations avec
l'Allemagne qui sont très dégradées
c'est quand même très préoccupant il dit
les erreurs stratégiques majeures en
matière d'énergie donc il dit aussi que
si c'était un refrain à refaire il
appellerait à nouveau à voter pour
Emmanuel Macron parce qu'en gros ce qui
dit s'il y avait personne de crédible
chez elle
dit qu'il n'aurait jamais voté pour Le
Pen et ou pour Mélenchon qui ne voulait
pas d'un duel Le Pen Mélenchon en quoi
nous ce la droite n'était pas en
capacité d'être sauvée moi je considère
que
pour moi Nicolas Sarkozy est libre de sa
parole aujourd'hui
comme hier mais il a dit aussi qu'il
sortait du jeu politique qui ne voulait
pas se mêler donc il aurait dû
s'abstenir de de politique donc je veux
en rester là
tournent la page du sarkozyme on entend
ça chez des candidats à la présidence
est-ce que vous dites bah oui il faut
tourner la page du sarkozyme aujourd'hui
Nicolas Sarkozy elle est républicain
c'est terminé
alors il garde des amis chez les
républicains tout enfin dans cet
interview très très longue il dit un
certain nombre de choses
auxquelles on peut souscrire ça a été un
grand chef d'État donc voilà on tourne
on n'oublie pas ce qu'il a été on
n'oublie pas ce qu'il a apporté à notre
pays et ce qu'il a apporté à la droite
maintenant il a dit très clairement
qu'il ne voulait pas se mêler notamment
à l'élection interne il ne prendra pas
partie ne votera pas j'entends aussi sa
volonté de recul bon en même temps il
existe un problème majeur de digeur de
leadership et stratégie chez les
républicains
donc il se met pas de l'élection mais
enfin il met le loi là où ça fait mal
alors il y a deux choses leadership et
stratégie il est clair que dans les
années qui viennent on aura besoin d'une
incarnation forte parce que
notamment en 2027 on ne lit pas un parti
politique on délit un homme ou une femme
on est une personne
des républicains et puis sur la question
de la stratégie vous voyez que c'est une
stratégie qu'il nous faut sans expliquer
mais qui est la stratégie de la
responsabilité imaginons un peu que les
républicains
se mettent dans la roue de la France
insoumise par exemple en votant
comment voulez-vous que les Français
nous accordent ensuite leur confiance et
n'est pas possible donc la stratégie
bien sûr elle est elle est censée ça
ajuster à l'actualité au texte mais
quand même sur les fondamentaux nous
sommes nous sommes d'accord nous n'avons
jamais varié sur nos fondamentaux je
prends deux exemples celui de l'énergie
de la politique énergétique si nous
avions poursuivi la politique initiée
par Georges Pompidou et conduite de
façon invariante par tous les présidents
de droite qui lui ont succédé on ne
serait pas dans la difficulté dans
laquelle on se retrouve aujourd'hui si
on avait
réformé les retraites si on avait
continué à combattre l'immigration
illégale et intensifier les obligations
de quitter le territoire français vous
avez regardé les chiffres l'effondrement
depuis 2012 depuis que Nicolas Sarkozy a
quitté le gouvernement donc en matière
de stratégie on ne peut pas dire qu'il y
a des Stop and Go ou des allers-retours
ou des ou des revirements on a une
colonne vertébrale les républicains
savent où ils habitent mais il y a un
problème d'incarnation ça vous le
reconnaisse mais alors ça c'était pour
répondre à la stratégie après
l'incarnation ça viendra en son temps
certains considèrent qu'il faut le faire
dans les mois qui viennent
d'autres considèrent qu'il faut il y a
une chose qui est certaine c'est
qu'est-ce que vous considérez est-ce que
clairement il faut désigner votre
candidat à la présidentielle dès le
début 2023 alors je crois qu'il faut
interroger le candidat en question
puisque l'un des candidats à la
présidence de la primaire a clairement
désigné son candidat donc je pense que
la moindre des choses
voilà évoquer c'est la bonne incarnation
pour les républicains il faut interroger
l'intéresser pour savoir s'il veut
rentrer dans l'arène aussitôt
pour votre partie puisque vous le
président est-ce que l'intérêt c'est
d'avoir votre candidat à la
présidentielle dès maintenant ou c'est
d'abord de refonder le parti sur les
idées c'est un peu ce que peuvent faire
Bruno retaille au d'abord on refonte le
parti sur les idées et après on se
choisit une incarnation sera tranchée
par le futur président il faut pas se
tromper de moments la politique c'est
aussi une question non même Tom si vous
vous trompez de moments donc il faut
bien ajuster les choses ce que je sais
en revanche c'est que
aujourd'hui le parti politique ne sera
les républicains ne sera plus présidée
par quelqu'un qui a vocation à être
candidat à la présidentielle ça veut
dire qu'il faut reconfigurer le parti
dans une autre fonction que celle qu'on
lui a toujours connu et c'est un
changement qui n'est pas qui n'est pas
indifférent ça veut dire aussi que la
culture du chef oui mais enfin bon
toujours mais donc le parti c'est
l'outil au service de la conquête du
pouvoir c'est aussi le lieu où s'élabore
les stratégies que où c'est laborent la
la structure idéologique ou se débattre
les sujets et en la matière il y a il y
a à faire bien sûr parce que la société
mobile étant son changeant les
situations et on le voit dans de
multiples domaines exigent des réactions
rapides ajustées proportionnées donc ce
travail ce travail de fond doit être
fait en permanence par le parti pour le
moment venu se mettre au service du coup
ça veut dire que pour vous ni Bruno
Retailleau ni Aurélien Pradier j'écarte
avec ce type puisque lui-même a écarté
sa hypothèse donc ni Bruno retaille au
ni Aurélien pradienne en vocation avec
votre candidat à la présidentielle même
s'il gagne la présidence du parti
écoutez
je ne les ai pas entendus tenir de
telles propos en tout cas il faut savoir
raison garder là on est dans l'élection
à la présidence de LR ne mélangeons pas
les gens moi j'ai compris je n'ai pas
compris que l'un d'entre eux pouvait
tenter par la présidentielle une
dernière question sur les républicains
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qu'il en reste
du parti aujourd'hui vous avez combien
de militants est-ce que la l'élection
qui s'approche ou fait qu'il y a un
regain ou est-ce que la séquence telle
qu'on voit ce qui est en train de se
passer à la à l'Assemblée à l'inverse de
nature à écarter encore un certain
nombre de gens des républicains
les républicains c'est plus de 70 000
adhérents je pense qu'on tutoiera les 80
000 au moment de l'élection du moment de
la clôture des adhésions le 3 novembre
c'est le premier parti en nombre
d'adhérents c'est sans fédération dans
tous les territoires de France c'est un
lieu où qui a des instances qui se
réunissent régulièrement c'est un lieu
où on débat des sujets où on propose des
solutions les conventions que Christian
Jacob avait mise en œuvre on produit
énormément de propositions sur
lesquelles nous sommes encore
en train de nous nourrir donc on est
parti en nombre d'adhérents absolument
on a des rampants alors en cotisation
payante
sont ceux qui s'engagent qui payent une
cotisation j'ai plus de plus adhérents
que le rassemblement national mais bien
sûr mais bien sûr regardez les chiffres
regardez les chiffres donc
voilà soyons conscients de ce que nous
sommes
sur l'avenir de votre partie puisque là
il y aura un chef avant Noël le second
tour c'est le 10 et 11 décembre est-ce
que selon ce chef est notamment si c'est
Éric Ciotti vous craignez des divisions
vous créez une implosion du parti les
républicains je vais vous donner mon
sentiment
je ne le crois pas vraiment je ne le
crois pas parce que
partir DLR pour aller où alors j
distingue les politiques les
responsables politiques des adhérents
il appartiendra en tout cas à celui qui
se sera fait élire de rassembler
aujourd'hui
ils veulent gagner demain ils devront
rassembler Eric ce type rassembler les
centres ah celui qui sera élu devra
ramener les autres mais les autres
candidats devront participer à cette à
cette union cette réunion parce que ben
il en va de leur responsabilité vous
dites pas vous savez le pire n'est
jamais sûr on nous a dit tellement
souvent que les républicains c'était
fini c'était en réalité on voit que on
est en permanence la cible de critiques
et data convergentes c'est donc qu'on
représente quelque chose et ça j'en suis
profondément puisque vous dites partir
pour aller où il y a Édouard Philippe
qui tend les bras à toute à tous les
gens qui veulent quitter les
républicains parce que les républicains
seraient trop à droite ça va pas être
lui le grand gagnant de la course à la
Présidente je n'y crois pas parce que
Édouard Philippe est quand même
comptable d'un bilan le bilan du premier
d'une bonne partie du premier
quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron c'est lui
les gilets jaunes les 80 km/h le début
de l'explosion des dépenses publiques
etc etc donc voilà Édouard Philippe
c'est Macron
un dernier mot Stéphane rapidement email
Macron a rencontré Georgia Méli à
l'occasion de sa visite à Rome est-ce
que vous pensez que c'était une bonne
chose premier une chef d'État à la
rencontre comment est-ce que vous voyez
ça
Giorgia Meloni a été élu
démocratiquement moi je suis très
attachée à l'expression du suffrage
voilà donc je pense qu'il faut
reconnaître la légitimité le peuple
italien et souverain c'est un grand
peuple un peuplamié un grand peuple
européen c'est pour ça que la réaction
de Madame Vander Leyen était pour le
mois décalé je crois bon il l'a
rencontré mais en catimini le soir en la
faisant entrée par une porte dérobées on
voit bien qu'il assume pas complètement
on soit elle est reconnue comme un chef
de gouvernement comme un autre et on la
rencontre à visage découvert soit on
considère qu'elle n'est pas fréquentable
dans ce cas là on ne la rencontre pas on
n'est pas du tout en même temps c'est ce
que vous nous dites voilà c'est une fois
de plus dure en même temps moi je
considère qu'il était qu'il est normal
de rencontrer la dirigeante de la
nouvelle dirigeante de l'Italie voilà
merci Annie jeune va merci beaucoup
d'avoir été